hello everyone and welcome to a very
special video as today is the day uh
when legendary grand master yuri
averbach is celebrating his 100th
birthday and it's hard to uh well to
condense such a such such an
accomplishment into one video uh but i
decided to show a game from the 1954
ussr championship against uh a legend in
his own right effing gallery you guys
know a lot about him since we've covered
many of his games and while he was
around
during
many of our sagas uh and it's a very
special tournament for averbach as he
wasn't a very well-known player in those
days he only became a grand master like
two years in 1952 so two years before
this tournament and even though they
knew why everyone was invited because
they've invited 20 of the strongest
players of that uh
era
for from the soviet union uh
they either had to have like a specific
result from a certain tournament or have
had a really really impressive results
over the course of the half of the year
or something like that but it is uh i
believe still unknown why averbach was
invited here but history enjoys such
events as uh if you guys remember from
the capablanca saga there is a very uh
certain tournament where capablanca
when capoblanca arrived they didn't
really think that he belonged there
because this is only for really really
strong players so there was even that
clash with arun nymsovich but well we
all know how that ended as you guys
watched the capablanca saga uh so now
this is uh very very similar uh and uh
he he
basically came on the scene uh by
winning the 1949 uh moscow championship
so that was his first big event uh then
uh well
we have him here he he played in the
candidates tournament once in 1950 uh in
1953 and he came this close to
qualifying for the 1959 candidates
tournament the legendary uh one where
well we all we all know who won uh by by
playing the 1958 um uh inter-zonal
tournament in porto roche he was half a
point uh behind the the uh you know uh
the required uh the requirement for for
qualification for the candidates
tournament uh but that being said this
is a very special uh tournament and this
this is the game i chose i could choose
any other because he has so so many
great games uh you guys will enjoy this
one so without further ado let's check
it out and geller has the white pieces
and he opens with uh e4 uh averbach
plays c5 he goes for the sicilian
defense knight to f3 we have knight to
c6 and now d3 geller goes for the old
sicilian defense
we have g6 and now g3 preparing the
castle so this is a system you can play
pretty much against uh
not against everything but against a lot
of stuff you're gonna think after the
lights were bishop castle king side and
you will play something like a4 to
prevent b5 and you wanted the c4 square
for your knight here so it's a very
solid system you can play against a lot
of things even today so bishop to g7 we
have bishop to g2 and d6 uh and uh yeah
uh i forgot to mention averbach was uh
around for uh so many historical uh
events that he was uh okay he he didn't
uh he wasn't alive during the alaska
capablanca match for the world chess
championship but he was born like eight
months or something uh aft after that
match so he was around for uh he is
still around for a very very long time
so here we have castles by uh geller we
have knight to f6 and knight b to d2 so
like we said we want to play a4 put the
knight on c4 and this will be a very
good setup we're going to have a very
nice control over the e5 square and
white is perfectly fine here so here we
have castles and a4 uh securing that c4
square for the knight so we can't chase
it away we have bishop to d7 knight to
c4 and now the the position uh can very
well happen even today uh queen to c7 is
a known move uh by by today's standards
but here averbach just plays d5 he says
all right i'm not allowing you to
continue in your safe system let's open
up the center and see what happens now
you could play knight to the e5 uh makes
sense as black vacated the square but
now just e captures on the five knight
captures and rook to e1 and it is now as
of move 11 that this position has never
been reached again uh since 1954.
uh and now we have queen to c7
continues the queen he connects the
rooks uh and it's white to move so
knight to g5 it's a good square for the
knight uh if black wants to kick it away
you're going to have to weaken your king
side and until you do so we are not
moving our knight from from g5 also now
you could start pushing those pawns
maybe h4 h5 everything is on the table
we have knight b6 offering a trait of
knights here as this knight is
excellently placed on c4 and knight back
to e3 uh we have a5 now and uh white
starts the attack with h4 now h5 is
coming so yuri says okay now let's kick
the knight away with h6 we have knight
to the e4 and now knight to d4 now
saying okay you're going to play c3 at
some point i'm going to shift my knight
over to f5 so here we have h5 first
g5 of course we're not opening up the
position and c3 kicking away the knight
knight to f5 and now uh queen to b3 so a
nice square for the queen asking black
what do you do here so black of course
not interested in trading and helping
wise develop his pieces he just goes
knight back to d6 says okay if you want
to capture
i'm gonna capture and then we'll i will
have a very strong center
so knight to d5 attacking the queen and
the knight here we have captures
captures and the knock comes knight
captures on e4 we have queen captures on
e4 uh seemingly attacking these seven
pawn but not really other bug just plays
brook to b8 he says you are welcome to
grab the pawn but capturing the pawn uh
you know just equals uh game over
because after rook e8 your queen does
not have a square so you just have to
part with the queen so after rook to b8
queen to d5 was played now k rook
captures on e7 is a threat so e6
attacking the queen queen back to a2 and
now comes bishop to c6 offering a trade
of bishops so queen back to c4 now
saying if the bishops get traded off
maybe i can play d4 you're not going to
be able to capture since your queen will
be hanging and it's a much more active
square as uh
unlike the a2 square so here bishop
captures on g2 king captures and queen
to c6 check we have queen the e for now
offering a queen trade and rook f2d8 now
avobach says you are welcome to double
my pawns here but that's not really to
do all that much you have a backwards d3
pawn and i'm just going to double up
rooks and the d file your my position is
just better and of course giller agrees
with this so he just continues
development bishop to e3
and now rook to d5 not just the
defending this but also preparing to
double rooks and the d file as we
mentioned the d3 pawn is a backwards
pawn it's going to be very weak here we
have rook 8 to d1 and it's a move uh
that pretty much anyone would play you
want to bring more more defenders to the
d3 pawn but it doesn't work but white's
position is really really bad even
though it's hard to realize why aside
from having this d3 d3 weak pawn uh you
have to play something like c4 and it's
uh it's an ugly thing to do but uh
it it kind of has to be done uh for
example c4 we're gonna play queen rook
captures on d3 and you've lost this pawn
the rook cannot be captured because the
queen is spin but it's hard to
understand why you would make such an
ugly move here rook 8 to d1 was played
and now the problem is uh white is
completely lost but black has several
good moves to choose from and it's not
easy
it's not always easy to find the killer
blow
when you have many good moves to choose
from but you guys are comfortable in
your own homes over 60 years have passed
since this game so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find this
incredible idea for black while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on writing the wrong
so many years later and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course pawn to f5 and now when you see
this move you might think all right what
happens next i'm just going to move my
queen so queen to f3
now we play g4 okay we move the queen
even further queen to e2 now we play f4
and we can never forget that
the queen and the king are on the same
diagonal and now the problem is if you
capture with the bishop rook e5 check
and that's it you lose the queen
nothing to be done here and if you don't
after e4 you could capture with the g
pawn doesn't matter we're just gonna
play whatever rook captures on h5 and
now how do you defend this you are in
check uh if you move the king you are
getting checkmated with rook to h1 so
you have to play something like f3 but
then g captures on f3 queen captures and
now rook to h2 with check and you have
to part with your queen of course king
g3 is met with rook to h3 check once you
capture queen captures on f3 so
everything is uh
losing here and well it's it's a very
tricky move to find but uh like i said
it's easier to find such a move when you
don't have
any other good moves but here uh avarbak
played rook beat d8 and his position is
still much much better so he didn't
maybe want to spend all that much time
uh and
if you don't know that it's there it's
uh you know not all that difficult to
miss it so here geller realizes what's
going on he quickly plays king to f1 and
now we have c4 now this is what averbach
saw uh he said all right now you can't
really capture i'm allowing you to play
d4 which is good for white but you are
losing the a4 pawn and then i'm just
gonna play b5 b4 and win the game so
that's the plan so here d4 we have queen
captures on a4 and now g4 are preparing
to start an attack here because that's
pretty much all that's left uh queen
back to d7 getting ready to push those
queen side pawns and now rook to a1
we have a4 uh and now rook to e2 we have
b5 uh and now rook a to e1 so white can
just wait and see what happens but uh
avid does not rest he just continues
attacking b4
and now if you capture this then bishop
captures and e4 white's position just
falls apart so instead after b4 we have
f4 uh now trying to create some sort of
a kingside attack maybe if the maybe if
this opens up something something then
maybe rook can come here maybe we can do
something it's all very far-fetched but
you have to you have to try so g
captures on f4 bishop captures on f4 and
now a3 so we're creating a pass pawn
regardless of what uh white plays uh
rook to g2 now preparing to push the
pawn and now not rushing with anything
on the queen side even though you could
perfectly uh play this perfectly fine
just queen e7 we regain control over the
g5 square and white is without any real
threat so queen to e3 adding another
piece the uh cover the g5 square but now
just queen f6 spinning the bishop so
king to g1 and now a captures on b2 so
here averbach allows g5 but he
calculates everything precisely
and that's why this game is so cool g5h
captures on g5 now not bishop captures
if you capture with the bishop we can
just give up the rook here uh because
well now be captures in c3 and that
well those past pawns are just
unstoppable the queen cannot capture as
the rook is hanging here so no play
there so instead bishop to e5 now saying
okay if you move the queen rook captures
on g5 or queen captures and then it's
game over so of course now avarbak has
to give up the exchange a rook captures
on e5 d captures on e5 and now queen
captures on e5 even this because the
pawn mass on the queen side is just too
powerful queen captures bishop captures
and now rook captures on g5 and other
back doesn't even try to cover with the
bishop he just plays king to h7 and now
look at this rook g captures on e5
b captures on c3 now the past pawns are
incredible but you are down the rook so
here rook to b5
ready uh
if c2 then we can pick up the b2 pawn
it's perfectly fine to play c2 but
averbach decides to end the game in
great style he plays rook to d1 and he
was in this position on move 46 that
effinghaller resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh the rook will be captured if you
capture blackstroke then c2 comes with
tempo and now the pawns are just too
strong if rook f1 we're gonna bring a
queen into the game and that's it for
example captures captures uh you you are
now in a lost end game
and of course if you don't after rook to
d1 you can play some like king f1 but it
doesn't matter just c2 uh and now after
well whatever rook captures on b2 we can
play rook captures king captures c1
check we're going to pick up the rook as
well and the game is completely winning
so that's uh the game is enjoyable for
many reasons one for for missing the df5
it's uh you know really really crushing
i don't know the situation on the clock
here so the the
other buck could have been in time
trouble but also it's not that that easy
to spot uh especially if you have
another good move that just forces a
winning position
uh so i hope you guys enjoyed this and
just so we don't forget let's also check
out the standings of the 1954 uh ussr
championship uh here are the standings
as you can see uh averbach won first
place ahead of some incredible names
here with 14 and a half out of 19. so
full point and a half uh ahead of
players like cortney tamanov petrosia
and lisa in como of sweden even the
rashid medina played here furman bishop
effinghaler borisenko flor
incredible incredible names like i said
20 of the strongest players of the
soviet union were invited to play in
this tournament and avarbak prevailed
against against them as you can see uh
10 wins zero losses and nine draws
that's just incredible uh the only other
player okay
some other players have had zero losses
but you can see that taiman of also zero
losses but 12 draws uh and also
interesting fact um aver bach's daughter
um can't remember the name but
averbach's daughter married
mark taymanov
so that's uh you know fun fact to know
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh so many of you
suggested i show a game for his 100th
birthday
and of course i was going to do that
either way but um yeah always uh thank
you for for suggesting uh great great
stuff
uh so if you if you guys know of a
certain game that we could show like i
said i've checked out many and this is
the one i i decided to show because it's
super enjoyable so i hope you enjoyed
that as well but yeah feel free to use
hashtag suggestion if you have any more
uh cool recommendations
uh so yeah i hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank patrick mulcair uh
my couch for providing a place for
meadow to chill uh tepsley for being the
best richard knapp and the hoodie knight
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
grand prix
until it ends uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day